c'est risqué succéder
je mets ce matin j'ai failli ne pas
venir ici
tout simplement parce que sous désolé je
suis connecté facebook mais samus aran
ce matin j'ai écrit dérisoire tout le
reste est bien que cet après midi je
vends intervenir sur le thème qu'il faut
croire en ses rêves et vous savez ce qui
s'est passé ça que je me suis levée et
du
le reste des régions comment je vais
venir au paris il faut croire en ses
rêves
cet après midi bah j'ai deux amis by ap
kim a répondu il faut y aller d'autant
plus que maya n'a pas tort william a
donné beaucoup de courage
et puis j'ai moore africa international
est quelqu'un que je ne connais pas
virtuel j'aimerais beaucoup un jour le
rencontrer je sais c'est un animateur à
mayotte et qui écrit ces épreuves
doivent nous permettre peut-être encore
plus unis et faire comprendre d'autres
qu'il faut croire en ses ailes voilà ce
qu'il m'a écrit donc je suis si cet
après midi
oulala c'est risqué cette histoire-là
mai
c'est pas grave et du coup j'ai changé
tous les plans parce que tout ce que
j'avais préparé pendant trois semaines
un mois les répète et tout ça ça tombe à
l'eau non je vais leur parler de
vendredi selon audi on dit matin par
vendredi l'a dit que c'était assez
dramatique et j'avais peur de vous
plomber cet après-midi en terminant cet
après-midi en parlant il faut croire en
ses rêves répond quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé hier soir donc je me suis
dit je vais parler de ma matinée de
vendredi
c'est vrai que je suis connecté non
parce que les terres vraie vie celle de
tous les jours le quotidien
il est là c'était hier
donc ce vendredi matin je l'avais comme
d'habitude je m'occupe de jeunes en
difficulté je vends n'occupe
bénévolement je vais les retrouver dans
enfants par petits groupes ils ont 18 et
25 20 et je le faire faire un exercice
un peu bizarre qu'elle s'attende pas de
leurs proches de leur vie privée y
connaît un stylo on va travailler
je sais que tu as ne savons rien de
travailler mais faut pas le faire déjà
j'ai les visages qui se plombe un petit
peu 32 heures ces gars là il va les
faire travailler
c'est l'entretien on n'a pas trop les
fatiguer
ce vendredi j'en ai vu quelques années
un peu fatigué envie de terminer ça et
je leur dis pas boudé prendre un stylo
et sept foyers vous allez écrire de quoi
vous rêviez quand vous étiez petit de
quoi vous rêvez aujourd'hui et de quoi
vous aimeriez rêver demain tel monsieur
noah puis il se fera sous leur aile
ah je dis là vous n'aurez pas d' excuses
à me dire que vous n'avez pas
d'allocation que vous n'avez pas si on
n'est pas d'argent qu'on n'est pas parce
que le rêve c'est gratuit c'est ensuite
dans la salle que barack obama que comme
marley le mad apple que moi on a tous le
droit de rêver il n'y a pas d'examen
y a pas permis il n'y a pas de droit
d'entrée donc répond malheureusement
cette nuit là il ya des gens qui rêvent
de détruire notre monde et le aussi y
croit on puis désespoir alors le mans le
rêve n'appartient à personne et aux
riches ni au port ni aux humains ni aux
terroristes dit aux amoureux liés aux
ambitieux mais aux singles et il
appartient
que mon amour à de rêver donc je me suis
dit je vais vous parler de ma matinée de
vendredi matin et je vais vous parler de
dimitri 18 ans et de tatiana lé 22 ans
est d'abord d'être que je vais vous
parler un peu noir pourquoi est-ce que
je cours à sukkur séparer tout c'est
juste un échange d'un dialogue parfois
pour aider les gens dans la vie il faut
rencontrer les gens juste une rencontre
du changement dans un sens comme de cet
état diana ma'afu m'a bouleversé celle
de dimitri
mais je leur ai dit vous savez moi j'ai
vu j'ai réalisé deux rêves dans ma vie
je voulais être journaliste
parce que je suis un mec va derrière la
redoute et que j'allais on avait comme
seul loisir d'aller au stade de la
redoute voir des matchs de foot n'est
pas trop d'argent
sautez burkhard y aura des matches et je
voyais toujours ce monsieur qui à la fin
du match aller dans les vestiaires
discuter interviewé tu ne correspond pas
vous avez dix ans à l'époque a dit
bernard surtout journalistes je veux
être au lit et je suis devenu
journaliste je suis pas trop mal sorti
j'ai démarré comme correspondant et j'ai
fini comme rédacteur en chef d'un gang
ou ici sur les manières dont le cadre là
ça fait tellement gagner au mans j'ai
pas fait d'études je suis débrouillé
tout seul je sais plus comment mais je
veux faire sucre il est rouillé et je
suis arrivé l'objet et le deuxième rêve
je rêvais d'aller aux états unis
je rêvais et je suis allé aux états unis
l'un des jeunes hommes qui dit je cale
ville à visiter la visite à miser tout
le tour et même montréal je serai pas
aux etats unis c'est banal
j'ai travaillé j'ai fait la plonge dans
un restaurant bavière j'ai travaillé dur
avec home server et dans merdier faisait
beaucoup beaucoup de déchet l'assemblée
mais sous et je suis allé aux états unis
et ainsi je me suis retrouvé dans cet
avion
quelques-uns de la génération ici il
connaît joe dassin et joe dassin chanter
la mairie de l'aviron que je le veux et
je l'aurai et je me vois encore là ce
soir entrer dans cet avion dynamique et
gt entre eux
new york entre paris et new york
pas trop téméraire est prêt ou non juste
deux mois les cinq entre deux patrons
manama les malaises de grêle mais vous
n'êtes cycliste professionnel parce
qu'un jour un noël - gagnez un vélo le
bordereau tournoi cette puce comme
celui-là lé matin cinq moines encore des
rêves on encore beaucoup de rêves à 57
ans tout à l'heure la parade au dos un
rêve
pourtant peut-être que ce type l'oréal
du coup je parlais dimitri et bastia
dimitri 18 ans quitte l'école
il veut retourner à lyon il veut rendre
sa famille heureuse il veut directeur
d'une grande chaîne de fast food
je prend d'habitude les filles si on
analyse on regarde les priorités on
s'amuse un petit peu avec et je demande
à dimitri petites actions beurre qui
très marrant tu parles c'est une amie et
twenty mais dimitri pour pat a quitté le
père a quitté l'école son accent la
salle que j'ai fait des bêtises à jeudi
mais on glass si tu avais fait autant de
bêtises que moi 57 ans je te souhaite
l'arrivée je suis toutes les bêtises que
j'ai pu faire
il me regarde dans les yeux il dit
monsieur c'est la première fois qu'on
parle tout qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
l'extraordinaire dit d'habitude quand je
dis que j'ai fait des bêtises
olivier de schutter peut-être les filles
rédaction et nous on dit ça fait notre
raison du match joie tu peut-être aller
chercher ton rêve là on va voir qui est
d'habitude tout le monde a des repas
secours un peu singulier dont kanak
héros des siens mais maintenant ça fait
presque six mois que je
secco et je m'amuse beaucoup parce que
je sais quand en chemin j'en ai quitté
michel rollin la feuille des billets au
départ je voulais pas révélatrice oui je
et vendredi nous étions un peu en avance
ne sont pas très nombreux nous restait
un quart d'heure est allé tatiana
tatiana ne disait rien tatiana n'a rien
écrit et moi je suis ni psychologue je
suis pas un élu donc je leur vends rien
je leur demande rien à côté pour moi je
suis pas fils je suis pas proche de ne
pas et peut-être et tatiana comme
quelques-uns ne voulait pas revenir sa
feuille
parce qu'elle sait pas écrire que ça
fait beaucoup de fautes aux monnaies et
et tatiana j'insiste un peu ta dernière
le dis clairement ce délit ne peut être
que ces deux heures à discuter en
cassant les pluies en leur disant telles
choses en leur disant mais tu sais dans
la salle laval à bout peut-être plus là
vous savez rêver c'est aussi rêver d'un
café et d'une louche une sieste ça vous
arrive et non rajouter juste le mot je
rêve d'un bon café
je rêve d'une bonne douche ou d'une
bonne sieste
découvrez comment
déjà plus heureux que diana noté mais
monsieur moi j'ai rêvé de faire de la
boxe thaï
aujourd'hui je rêve d'être de vendeuse
je rêve peut-être couturière peut-être
aussi wafers je dis oui mais alors
qu'est-ce qui se plaint tatiana du temps
qu'est ce qui l'a empêché de faire la
bonne taille
je vois les yeux de tatiana qui
rougissent j'en ai déjà eu deux filles
dans ce cas là tatiana people et ce
match là qui passe moi juin j'ai un
petit peu l'habitude dont je la laisse
espérer jeudi tatania tathiana garbin
pourquoi est ce que tu peux pas les
obstacles parce que moment là bas les
points arles on paye ma cotisation
après on analyse
ses rêves de profession tatiana tu as 22
ans est un petit verre pour il a 5 ans
j'étais un coup tatiana on va faire
comme pour les autres on va être les 1 2
3 4 et on va positionner des priorités à
ce contretemps
quand je donne ces échanges je leur
explique qu'un rêve ça parle là jusqu'à
un rêve c'est loin mais quand on peut
mettre des petits drapeaux escalade et
rognac et puis parfois il faut prendre
l'escalier c'est à dire monter marche
par marche ne pas faire trois marches il
est arrivé et on n'y a donc que tatiana
on va classer des priorités des joies
son visage mais qui hélas la première
des priorités c'est la grosse taille ce
sens à sa part on va mettre un indice
parce que la toute première c'est quand
même de trouver du travail pour ta pour
ton petit garçon du site wat
on va voir comment comment on peut le
faire mais la boxe thaï on va le mettre
dans un bisse ouailles à rêver d'une
vérité d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui
quand on démarre mal y avait rien pour
nous il n'y a pas de location il n'y
avait rien
vous conseillez vos process
départementale pardon il existe un fond
d'oeil au jeu
qui peut me permettre de payer la
cotisation de kopstal parce que dans la
vie pour réussir sa vie faut des projets
un rêve c'est construire un projet donc
toi on va y aller et j'ai lu tatiana
partir de la salle des grands sourires
avec quelque chose les voies naturelles
selon l'un des jeunes c'est de ne pas
parler si tu ne m'avait pas parlé on se
seraient pas rencontrés à sept pas tous
les jours donc voilà je crois qu'il faut
essayer de croire en ses rêves
je voudrais que tout le monde y arrive
c'est pas par hasard que les plus
grandes citations reprennent morel celle
de martin lüthi vous la connaissez alp
celle de saint-exupéry vous la
connaissez fait que le rêve devant votre
vie avant que la vie dévoraient et je
leur parle à ses jeux 10h10 ouailles à
la salle là nous sommes sept
il ya cette vie différent christ conduit
quelques départs de la question à la
troisième année mais ce n'est pas tout
chacun a sa vie ici on a la première des
villes cent cinquante ans saison et vous
verrez donc je le raconte trois
histoires celle du coach de la plus
grande championne de tennis qui voulait
être tennisman au qui n'a pas été mis
dans ce tennisman au pardon parce que
son père vienne n'a pas brûlé à son père
mais une très grosse entreprise qui
travaille chez moi
il a été 15 jours sur mon père ghazi
maintenant j'ai vu que j'ai travaillé
pendant deux garçons intelligents et
pourquoi non parce que je veux être
tennisman prochain
il est arrivé puisqu'il aujourd'hui les
poches de serena williams
mais son père du jour là j'ai dit oui
tout simplement parce que à l'époque
parce qu'il avait dit et je le veux être
prouvent les parents été inquiet c'est
pas un métier c'est pas me la passe
quand il est il a rencontré son père
pour son coaching s'est exporté potier
villa des mois je verse à son père ait
dit ça l'a surpris voilà un exemple la
donne la vie de françoise giroud qu'on
l'a retrouvé au bord du suicide parce
que je m'endorme la vérité et qui est
devenue une des plus grandes écrivaines
de france il ya aussi ce jeune homme qui
vivait dans une cabane avec sa mère
alcoolique d amant violent et qui
aujourd'hui est le pdg d'areva sont
elles qui a écrit un livre qui s'appelle
rien n'est perdu d'avancé
seul il commence le jour où il est
invité par barack obama
je vous invite à les oignons je vous
invite aussi et j'espère c'est le rêve
que j'ai la tête à leur devoir en un
monde meilleur
malgré tout ce qui se passe je vous
invite
je suis sûr vous l'avez déjà fait là un
beau souvenir du moment où vous rêviez
d'être
je souhaite à quoi infirmières faire le
tour du monde et peut-être parce que je
voulais vous parle vous serez souvient
de voitures et vélos
voilà ton sourire on a tout gagné
donc je vous remercie que je vous
parlais de mon erreur à 57 ans je
réinstalle l office world match
d'arsenal à l'emirates stadium
et que dit arthur on va y aller un
séjour elle suit le monde qui est pas
tous d'accord on va ici